well the new york times now admitting
there is an entire
industry built around manufacturing
stories and building
narratives to control public opinion and
the number one example of that
the steele dossier of course glenn
greenwald pulitzer prize winning
journalist has been warning us
about this for years and no one would
listen glenn
great to see you i have to tell you that
i spent the last five years in sports so
watching these kind of stories
a little bit from a distance and the
whole rush the story felt a little bit
like alice in wonderland another rabbit
hole
to fall into and i hate the word
misinformation but what we now realize
is stories like the steele dossier
weren't just false
they truly were misinformation were they
not
they were deliberate misinformation i
mean obviously you expect media outlets
to get things wrong
all do and then you promptly correct
them when that happens
this is something completely different
remember the article that was published
in the new york times which is
incredibly important i encourage
everybody to go read it was not a
article by a new york times reporter it
was a former new york times reporter who
has a new book out
and they published this excerpt i think
without realizing that they were
indicting themselves
the steele dossier was probably the most
important fraud in the last decade it
shaped american politics for years
and we now know that it was deliberately
coordinated and manufactured by these
private spy agencies working for the
democratic party fusion gps
in partnership with the u.s security
state that
and foreign security services that are
designed to disseminate this information
and they laundered it through the u.s
media
yeah and glenn the key here is the
journalists not
essentially neglecting to do their job
find their own sourcing find
documentation to back up the story
they're handed by these private security
companies
but it seems to me the key ingredient
here is confirmation bias you have to
believe this already
right for you to print something that is
coming to you only on the word of a
private security company you had to have
that bias built in
to believe it in other words they had to
believe the president trump allegations
to print it on so loosely sourced
exactly i think that's the key which is
that obviously if a private security
firm came to me and said i have
information i wouldn't turn them away
i'd want to hear what they had to say
maybe it's true
maybe the public should know it but i
would verify it i would want to see
evidence for it
and i wouldn't give them anonymity and
if it was just on their own say so and
if it turned out they lied to me as
these reporters now know
you are journalistically required to
expose them but what happened here was
the media got convinced that their
overarching priority was not to inform
the public but to destroy donald trump
and whatever they were given that was a
weapon to enable them to do it
they used it without the slightest
regard for whether or not it was true
that's the reality while i have you here
and i don't have much time left but i
just have to ask you a question out of
personal curiosity i've known who you
are for
quite some time and i would imagine it's
as big a surprise for you as it is for
me that you're sitting here on fox news
right now
sharing your opinion i'm sure there'll
be a point in the future glenn where you
and i disagree vigorously about
something
what brought you to this moment where
you feel like and you only have about a
minute i'm sorry but what brought you
this moment where you are
calling out the people that used to be
your compatriots
yeah you know i think that the trump era
really transformed almost every american
institution
and no matter what i think of president
trump's ideology and obviously i oppose
large parts of it
i think that when journalists start
abandoning their core obligation for
truth
it's the responsibility of everybody to
speak out and denounce it
because it's more dangerous than
anything they were accusing president
trump of doing and that's really what
motivated me
well you're always unpredictable always
interesting always smart glenn greenwald
thank you so much
for being here and that would be great
to be with you thank that will be the
goal
of this program this week to tell you
the truth hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else